e
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs uh we this
is going to be our committee orientation
today and we're delighted to have the
Department of Health and Human Services
the commissioner and and various others
with us as well as division three of
Finance uh before we get into the
proceedings however I would ask you to
Allegiance I pledge of allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
all before we uh welcome our guests and
have them come up and and uh talk about
the department and various other uh
matters I'd like to go around the room
and uh have the committee introduce
ourselves to the audience before the
audience introduces themselves to us my
name is Wayne McDonald I have the
privilege of being the chairman of this
committee
I'm in my third term in the house and I
represent the town of Londoner which is
Rockingham County District 16 I
representative
McGrath turn on your microphone put your
microphone on please representative
McGrath there's one right in front
Okay representative hartnet I talk loud
enough uh good afternoon I'm Tim hartnet
uh first term representative from
Manchester District 41 uh Wards 245 and
7 for those who are not familiar it's
really the uh uh the east side of inner
city
Manchester representative DW my name is
my name is Matt when the light is on
touch it once and then it'll St there
you go there you go the red
yeah my name is Matt Drew I represent
Ward 10 in Manchester on the West
Side representative Woods uh good
morning I'm Gary Woods I'm
represent maror ma 30 which is Ws floal
WS 567 and eight thank you
representative
damus I'm Sue damus from Farmington New
Hampshire District 1 um this is my
second term in the HHS and my fourth
term non-consecutive in the house thank
Weber thank you I'm Lucy Weber
um I represent uh chesher District 5
which is the towns of Walpole and Su
over on the Connecticut River or at
least Walpole is and Sorry's right in
Inland from that and uh I'm starting my
10th term in the house which is a matter
of some astonishment to me thank you
representative Maser thank you Mr chair
my name is representative Lisa merer and
I I represent the towns of gtown and
wear which is Hillsboro District 44 and
this is my second term welcome
everyone representative McCay thank you
Mr
chairman uh I'm uh starting my 28th uh
year and most of them has been on this
uh committee uh and I have the
unusual opportunity that most of them
don't have I represent the state house
this is right in the middle of w 4 in
conquer
representative McLean Mark mlan uh
representing uh Ward 8 in Manchester I
make light bulbs which doesn't have a
lot to do with HHS so I ask stupid
questions sometimes and I apologize in
advance but I'm just trying to
learn representative
lontine hi I'm Jessica lontine from uh
Dober which is and represent Ward five
which is straford County District 17 and
I'm in my second term in the
house representative palazov I'm yri
poov representing may mar district 10
hookit and Dan Barton it's my second
term in the house and second term in
this committee thank you representative
Palmer hi I'm Bill Palmer I represent
Cornish in planfield which is Sullivan
District 2 and this is my second term
thank you representative marel yes my
name is Jay marel I um represent
Atkinson New Hampshire which is uh
Rockingham County district 18 this is my
first ter thank you and last but not
least representative I'm Janet Lucas I
represent Grafton district 7 that is the
town of Campton and this is my first
term thank you all and welcome everyone
welcome back to the returning members
and welcome uh to the new members and
and I look forward to working with all
of you with that I would uh ask that um
we begin and I'd like to recognize the
commissioner of the Department of Health
commissioner
chair good afternoon thank you for uh
having me and my team here today to
speak with you about uh the department
who we are and what we what we do so so
um as uh representative McDonald had
said my name is Lori Weaver um I was
thinking I'm in the middle of my term um
which is uh four years um I've been with
the department for 28 years this year
going into my 28th year not all as
commissioner um I don't think anyone
could survive that um but really uh
coming into the department and
Leadership positions and in those 28
years various roles in the department um
and then in 22 um became interim
commissioner and then 23 became
permanent commissioner um so I do have
some familiarity with the Department
there's no stupid question so please do
ask us all questions um I am bringing
some materials to share with the
assumption that some of the community
members are new and may need to know or
would like to know a little bit more
about the department um the department
is large but it is not um something to
uh be afraid of in the sense that people
always say the department is large and
not knowing what that is it's actually
hoping today to put that into some
bite-sized pieces for you to digest uh
two years ago I believe I was here for a
meet and greet and at that time I had uh
my strategic priorities for the year of
23 when I was interim commissioner what
we called our road map um so that was
basically our strategic plan so what I'm
sharing with you today is our 2425 road
map commissioner yeah uh do you have any
extra copies I don't think we got got
enough for the side of the room did
everyone get one of these over there the
issue is the clerk needs copies and we
need copies for the two people who are
not here and I will get those we will
follow up and get those for you the good
news is it's also on our website so
folks in the interim um yeah of all of
that I wasn't quite sure of the number
of uh total number of members
um I know that a lot of my staff are
here today to be able just to say hello
to you and give you um an idea of who
they are names with faces and the areas
that they cover what I wanted to do with
you is just to sort of explain the
department a little bit at a high level
and then share with you what our
priorities are for 24 and 25 um so I'll
start with this sheet here that is the
two-pager um this basically is sort of
the cliffnote version if you will the
cheat sheet about the department so at
the very top we have our our vision
which is it's really quite simple op
Optimal Health and well-being for
everybody our agency is charged with
serving our vulnerable populations in
the state and we aim that all of our
citizens will have Optimal Health and
well-being um we have our mission
statement and then we have some our Val
some of our values we also have what our
primary responsibilities are so what
does the department do what are we
mandated to do required to do whether
it's federal or uh through state so
protection and prevention so you'll have
heard a lot about child protection
there's also adult protection services
Health disease obviously Medicaid is one
of our major funding sources that we use
to uh provide a lot of the program
services that we have Client Service
delivery we actually uh have about 50%
of our Workforce is what we call Direct
Care and that is providing either some s
some form of Case Management Services so
you'll think of a child protective
service worker or adult protective
service worker maybe a Child Support
Officer or an eligibility worker but we
also have uh 247 facilities uh we have
currently have four of them one is in
the process of being transitioned over
to a different provider um I have staff
that provide services so we have some
nurses we have Physicians we have
clinicians we do contract out some of
the Clinical Services of that but we
have a robust uh Workforce that provides
um the day-to-day skills needed whether
you're in a geriatric Psychiatric
Hospital such as glencliffe or you're in
New Hampshire hospital uh we have mental
health workers we have lnas we have food
nutrition and so on
um we also have uh Our Youth Development
Services Center which is down in
Manchester so we have direct staff uh uh
staff that provide Direct Services down
there as well so it's pretty pretty
robust and we also because it wouldn't
be government without regulatory
oversight um we also have that as well
so when you think about our nursing
facilities our child care facilities are
food right we do food licensing
restaurant licensing um our nursing
facilities so we work and go out and do
reviews uses um to make sure that
they're following what they're supposed
to be doing in their regulations so
that's a big part of HHS trying to break
it down into sort of a a palatable if
you look at it I've listed and give
given a little bit of a narrative of
each of the divisions so it's about it's
about eight divisions total six of them
are about programmatic uh uh direct
policy areas and two of them are really
supportive which is like your finance
and procurement and then our quality
improvement um and Assurance function so
we have Behavioral Health we have DCF we
have economic stability um uh long-term
Support Services Medicaid um public
health and of course I mentioned uh
quality and finance what I want to point
out is it seems like a lot of Divisions
but if we think about who we're serving
uh it's the families and the kids so all
of these divisions wrap around those
people that need services so it's not
siloed and segmented and if it is we
work to try to fix that the point would
be is that the staff from each of these
divisions work together collectively in
an integrated fashion to integrate
policy to integrate um Financial
supports to integrate Case Management
Services advocacy you name it um so
that's those pieces all fit together in
a choreographed way it isn't just these
random We'll add another one on and so
we have our finance folks to keep us in
check to make sure that we're not
spending more than we have been
allocated or authorized to do and then
we have our quality folks who basically
are saying are you doing it the way that
you're supposed to be doing it are we
accountable to those such as that give
us the funding source are we accountable
to those that we serve are we doing our
due diligence in serving the people of
New Hampshire so that's sort of how all
of those pieces work together my job is
to make sure that all the pieces
continue to work together and that all
these divisions are effective that I
have good leaders that can lead each
division that hire good staff to provide
those services and I sit here in front
of you today to tell you I'm very proud
that I have an excellent leadership team
many of whom you'll be working with
throughout session um and you'll get to
know them and they make themselves
available to you um whenever you have a
question whatever that might be um meet
with you whenever you need um so we are
here and want to be that resource to you
um I'll stop there before I go into road
mapap to ask if there's any clarifying
questions on structure any
questions any questions from division
three
just a small one representative edws on
this uh Madam commissioner on the uh
list here of the department leads I
don't see Patricia Tilly is is am I
blind or is she not on
here well I don't have the same list
that you have right now so I couldn't
tell you if you're blind or
not that's just our oh no so the list
that he's referring to is a list of what
we have for meet and greet today we did
if she left she didn't tell me I was
hoping she' buy me a beer well that's a
conversation for another time uh no uh
so we have uh a leadership
infrastructure which Trish uh is part of
that as well as um some other folks that
help assure uh all of what I was just
saying to make sure that we're we're
providing and doing what we're supposed
to be doing okay thank
you um moving to the the road map I on
the back of it isort again it's the
cliffnote version the reason I I shared
this is to give you an idea of the depth
and the breadth of when we're talking
about goals what are we actually looking
at so that's great that you're going to
improve customer service but what
specifically are you going to be doing
um so let me just walk you through the
three circles uh we pretty much put it
into three commitments which break down
um into 15 initiatives and 43 goals in
its entirety of the road map so our
first I'd like to start with a darker B
the bubble which is invest in people and
culture so it has been um a priority of
the department that we can't and that
they're staying and that they're doing
good quality work so you need to invest
in that in order to be able to do that
uh Second purple bubble is our promote
thriving
communities um that's where the bulk of
our policy work is and our program work
so you'll see some examples down below
there of initiatives that are happening
so if you look at Mission zero I'll give
that as an example some of you may or
may not have heard about that on the
news that's our Ed boarding that's our
emergency department boarding so we knew
uh a couple of years ago uh there was
some litigation there's always
litigation uh we didn't do it because of
the litigation um but there's litigation
uh to clear out uh emergency rooms and
not have folks wait there we all want
the same thing we don't want folks
sitting in emergency room either uh we
created Mission Z which basically was a
concerted effort to reduce that number
and through particular interventions I'm
happy to say to you today that we have
reduced significantly not only the
number of people that are sitting in EDS
but the time that they're sitting there
waiting for a bed um that's has taken a
lot of work in terms of resources and
system transformation but partnership
outside of the department we had to
actually partner with our Hospital
Association with our providers to be
able to say how do we work together to
make a dent here and we have U we made a
significant dent and we have that six
course strategies focused around that so
that's not just the front door it's also
when people are leaving care do they
have a place to go do they have a place
to live can they sustain and stay there
so you can read about that uh in further
depth uh within the um within the
document itself and I'd be happy to talk
to any of you about that as well um we
also have a couple other things on there
I just you know there's issues around
lead there's issues around you know one
of our issues is Healthy Mothers Healthy
Babies really making sure that people
are getting the care that they need
before they give give birth when they
give birth and postpartum as well um our
disability system developmental dis
disability system as well strengthening
that making sure that folks are getting
the services the right services that
they need when they need them um access
to community care whether that's whether
our system of care is whether you're a
senior or whether you're a child or a
youth or an adolescent we have systems
of care that we are responsible for
standing up and running to service those
needs so there those that's a real chalk
full I won't through all of them like I
said it's in your in your packet um but
that is what we're focusing on and
striving and when we look at our budget
and we look at our budget priorities our
budget priorities back up these
initiatives and that the things that we
know are going to make a difference to
the people in our state so a they're
getting care when they need it they're
not getting it languishing away in care
if they don't need it and that they're
in community as much as they can be um
the last bubble is improve customer
service um we have uh as you can imagine
uh a big reach in terms of who we serve
and I need to make sure that we as a
department are responsive um not only to
the people that we serve but all of the
systems that are tied in with that um so
making sure that it's easy for families
to understand how to navigate the
department making sure that it's easy
for um our provider Network who we rely
on to do a lot of our services we draw
down money from the feds we don't
necessarily provide the service we need
somebody to be able to do that we have
to have good relationships with our
providers to do that the procurement CR
process for the state um it's long it's
cumbersome working to improve that so if
you wanted to as a provider uh bid on a
contract it shouldn't be harder than it
is to provide the service and sometimes
historically it's been that way so we
for the last two years I've partnered
with our Center for um New Hampshire
profit uh nonprofit Association to be
able to engage our folks and say how can
we do this better how can we make this
easier um so that that partnership and
that collaboration is extremely
important so and constituent complaints
um I receive many in a day I read all of
them uh respond to all of them uh as
quickly as we can um and as thoroughly
as we can um and try to take the
information and feedback from that and
to do some improvement so that's not
continuing to happen so this is what
we're keeping our eye on over the next
uh two years this is a 2425 road map
there are some things in here that are
longer term there are some things that
are shorter term so what we we'll do
this spring we'll revisit where we're at
we have quarterly progress reports to
look at where we're at and then we'll
course correct and then we'll set out
another road map um probably in the
beginning of the summer as well that
will chunk out for the next year it's uh
sort of the easiest way for us to sort
of lay out the work and then attack it
and then also have some winds along the
way so so I know I've said a lot and I
know I talk fast um any questions any
any questions from the
committee division three U no
commissioner thank you very much
no apparently no one else is missing
that on the list thank you very much for
your time nice you can only drink one
uh okay next on the list I have um and
and I'm Ian
Edwards afternoon Mr
watt good afternoon thank you to the
committee for having me here today my
name is Ian watt I'm the director for
the division of Public Health Services
I've been with the department since 2021
and I've been uh serving this role since
uh the beginning of last year uh I
wanted just go over today a little
background on the division of Public
Health Services uh we are split into
seven bureaus with the primary goal to
protect the health of all people and
communities in the state of New
Hampshire where they live work in play
Public Health improves quality of life
helps Children and Families Thrive and
prevents human suffering with a focus on
activities and program that prevent
disease prevent injury and prevent
death the worth work of Public Health is
data driven we use data to focus the
resources available to us to be most
effective in serving our residents and
to educate people
uh about ways to stay healthy and
provide science-based solutions to
health related challenges in New
Hampshire our staff consists of a range
of professionals including Physicians
nurses epidemiologists Health Educators
restaurant inspectors social workers
evaluators nutritionists data analysts
scientists and laboratory workers Public
Health Pro promotes programs that
protect the health of our citizens
including preventing the spread of
disease and understanding and
investigating its prevalence uh by
example in the case of an instance of
tuberculosis in our state our Public
Health nurses would coordinate with a
patient to ensure that they receive
appropriate care and information around
their condition we would also then
coordinate with the community in any
potential exposures to make sure that
anyone else who may have been exposed uh
would be aware of potential health risks
and also have access to information and
resources to enable them to stay healthy
we educate people about the risks of
chronic diseases such as diabetes and
cancer we work closely with Community
organizations and Healthcare facilities
to ensure that vulnerable and atrisk
individuals receive access to timely
cancer screening and are aware of
programs for eligible individuals to PR
uh receive preventative care services
that maintain their health and save
costs and capacity in our healthare
system we also help prepare for and
respond to public emergencies and health
emergencies this includes as part of our
partnership with the Department of
Safety and home Homeland Security and
Emergency Management uh working as part
of the state Emergency Operations Center
where we support shelter and Medical
Care needs in the event of a public
emergency Public Health includes
programs that increase quality uh and
access to healthy foods and Quality
Healthcare uh as by example our Wick
program serves more than 16,000
low-income women and children under the
age of five to ensure access to
nutritious food to allow their families
to thrive we also work closely with our
community health centers including our
federally qualified Health Centers to
maintain access to basic health care
services across the state for low-income
vulnerable and Rural populations
uh we also include our State Office of
rural health and Primary Care working
with Partners in the community and our
Healthcare facilities to ensure adequate
Recruitment and Retention of the
healthcare Workforce we need to serve
the people of New
Hampshire these are just a few of the
ways that we serve uh the public as well
as public health impacts for residents I
finally I wanted to note that public
health also includes our Public Health
Laboratories whose mission is to protect
the Public's Health through responsive
unbiased quality clinical research and
environmental testing uh the public
health has a range of servic is
available among them are water wellwater
testing which allows homeowners to test
their well water and confirm their
access to safe and putable water we also
participate in national food
surveillance networks to identify
potential food contamination our food
supply and ensure that any food reaching
our tables is safe and healthy to
eat uh during this session you'll be
hearing from a range of our staff not
just myself on bills covering topics
such as maternal and child health uh we
always ensure are endorsed to ensure
that moms and babies across our state
receive the utmost care and attention uh
from our healthc care system and other
programs you'll hear from us on various
immunization bills to ensure that we
maintain access for all children and
families to routine life-saving
immunizations uh you'll hear about our
therapeutic cannabis program therapeutic
cannabis is a public health program
which serves approximately 15,000
patients and caregivers including
veterans cancer patients and people
suffering from chronic pain uh and
finally you'll hear from us on a number
of environmental health bills including
lead poisoning prevention related bills
to keep Ong going attention on lead
hazards in our communities and ways we
can keep our families and children safe
um and finally I want to make sure that
I have a chance to introduce a few
members of our team who were able to
join us today I'm not going to look
backwards the whole time so I'll I'll
trust them to stand up as I introduce
them I want to start with uh Courtney
Keane who is our bureau chief for family
health and nutrition uh family health
and nutrition includes our nutrition
programs such as Wick as well as our
maternal and child health
programs uh chawe chaa chawe is our
bureau chief for public health
statistics informatics she is our data
lead uh for the division focused on data
privacy and uh data
security I have Michael Hol joining me
Michael is our administrator for the
therapeutic cannabis program you'll hear
from Mike on a number of the bills
related to therapeutic cannabis access
uh and finally uh in person here today I
have Abby Rogers with us Abby Rogers is
our legislatively aison I'm sure many of
you are familiar with Abby she is an
enormous resource uh internally to our
organization and certainly to you all uh
as a coordinator as well as uh an expert
in a number of our programs uh not here
today I would did want to quickly
mention our Michelle Roberge who's our
Public Health protection uh bureau chief
that includes our lead program Colleen
Smith who is our infectious disease
bureau chief and Whitney Hammond who is
both currently our bureau chief for
prevention and wellness which includes
chronic disease as well as our interim
deputy director uh you'll also hear from
Dr Ben Chan who is part of our Public
Health division uh Dr Chan will will
appear in front of you to talk about a
number of the immunization bills and
that's all I have for present
presentation and happy to take any
questions or or other inquiry sure thank
you um did I see a hand up over
here no I guess I didn't yes
representative Woods thank you just a
very quick question overlapping with the
pasas commission uh when you are testing
Wells do you work with the in terms of
um sharing data relative to lid but also
pasas so it it would depend on the the
program and the inquiry uh in order to
share data due to you know the the
necessity of maintaining privacy and
health information uh we may need an
agreement with t yes but certainly we
work with them to ensure that data is
appropriate other questions
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair uh do do you think you have a few
minutes during this session for me to
introduce the division 3 people and
explain why uh it's important that
division 3 and HHS know each other sure
after Mr Watts is done um yeah if you
want to do that anytime in your hearing
is
sponsor but um anything else from Mr
wats representative
McKay just a very brief comment about
Michael Holt if he'd stand up again uh
he was with me on the five years that we
had to deal with medical
marijuana that was one of the most uh
I'd say educational
opportunities it was painful at times
and Michael was extreme ex remely
helpful and anybody that wants to know
anything about marijuana he's the man to
go
to thank you yeah M mic is a tremendous
resource thank you very much anything
else from Mr
Watts don't see anything okay thank you
sir thank
you and representative Edwards if you
want to briefly introduce division three
sure thank you so much I as a former
member of a Health and Human Services
committee I I really appreciate your
hospitality of bringing us in uh I think
over the years we figured out that for
uh freshman legislators and new people
to the uh uh two committees division 3
and HHS that it uh it was important to
share a general uh philosophy of how
hhsa is the policy committee and if uh
if this uh committee sees a good policy
and it gets it through the house with a
if it's got a fiscal note if it spends
money it'll come to division three so
we're like uh two sides of the same coin
your your policy we're Finance um
there's always I think been an A A
handshake agreement that uh each of our
committees would work together talk to
each other get to know each other's
members collaborate and have um your
your committee
uh also concerned about fiscal
responsibility and our committee being
appropriately concerned about whether
policies are sustainable and somehow
we've figured out how to make it work
for the last few years that's that's why
I think it was important to have
division three here so so that they can
learn about the department some of them
are brand new to us uh at this point I
i' like the division 3 members to stand
up and and and speak up and introduce
your
District represent Gary Daniels Milford
this is my 10th term in the house I was
nine terms in the on the lb committee
and I was in the senate for six years
Brian I
and and so the only one that's not here
is U uh the division 3 Vice chair
represented Moren Mooney from Mar ma
she's she's been a vice chair now for I
think this is going to be her third term
on division 3 and um she would be here
but she had to uh get home I think she's
watching us on TV if anyone wants to
wave to her at home but uh but so so
thank thank you Mr chair um I I really
appreciate the cooperation and having us
get off on the right foot for the the
coming term sure thank you
representative Edwards my
pleasure okay moving on um next I have
on the list uh Ernie Galan Galan or
Gan apologize if I mispronounced that
name is it Galan or Gillan or I think
somewhere in there came out right okay
it's Gillan actually so I'm Ernie Gillan
I am the director of Information
Services at the department I've been
with the department for a strong five
years and I became director in November
so today I wanted to talk about a little
bit
um as as you are certainly aware
technology is an integral part of every
service the department has to
offer um therefore you know making it
significant in how we approach all our
Solutions I want to talk about the the
uh areas that comprise Information
Services for the Department that is
project management and rise business
intelligence information
security department uh technology
strategy and support services that go
along with
that I'll talk to you briefly about
functions of each of those areas so with
the project management office that
really is operated for our Center of
Excellence for project management
project management office spends a lot
of time educating and developing project
managers at the business level so that
we can be significantly efficient in how
we get our projects accomplished and
turn those into
Services project management p uh is
responsible for portfolio governance
services and methodologies that
strategically address the highest
priorities of the
department Enterprise business
intelligence is our area where data
management data governance data
analytics and data warehousing and repor
needs are
accomplished information security is our
information risk management security and
privacy education and
awareness security incident response and
management and system privacy in
security from an IT strategic I
interrupt sure it may just be me and
tell me if it is
but Mr G speak a little closer just pull
the microphone a little closer
absolutely is this better yeah and it's
it's not just for us it's for the people
who are watching at all excellent thank
you thank you representative and I'll go
do a hearing
chair so from an IT strategic standpoint
our our approach is to help across the
department as our customers are not only
the department as a whole through every
program area but also everyone that they
serve so we approach Solutions in a way
that is privacy Centric and can make
more efficient and quicker
accomplishments to deliver those
Services as
well some of the support services as you
might guess would be Asset Management in
other words the handling of all the
equipment needed for our staff and needs
across Information Services has a strong
collaboration with the Department of
Information Technology we partner across
in almost every aspect that we have with
that with that separation but or really
delivery any questions I might be able
to answer any questions from the
committee seeing none um okay great
Hebert good after afternoon good
afternoon my name is Karen Hebert and I
am the director for the division of
economic stability very happy to be here
uh this afternoon for you so the
division of economic stability in
DHHS uh the mission of the division is
to enhance the health economic and
social well-being of individuals
families and
communities so we have a number of
values and anticipated outcomes that we
strive for it includes that individuals
and families have access to a means to
acquire life Necessities some who need
it permanently for a lifetime others who
may need it
temporarily this can include Health Care
utilities food and clothing and becoming
healthy and financially
stable we strive to support uh working
individuals and families and help them
to acquire and sustain gainful
employment to become
self-sufficient and financially more
secure we work to reduce poverty and
prevent poverty and the need for public
assistance we promote responsible
parenting Family self-sufficiency and
Child
well-being we seek to a uh provide
access to Services of high quality
reliable child care for Working Families
in the
state there are five
bureaus of this particular
division the first one is uh with
respect to Child Development and the
Head Start collaboration
office and this program establishes uh
means to creating a landscape where
every family can access a diverse
affordable and culturally responsible
needs we provide child support
services this is encouraging responsible
parenting Family self-sufficiency and
Child well-being by providing services
to locate parents establish
paternity establish modify and enforce
child support obligations and we obtain
and collect that child support and we uh
enforce medical support for children as
well we provide employment support
services for people assisting parents
with upward economic Mobility by
providing work or promoting work through
a provision of employment support and
Training Services that will strengthen
families improving child and family
well-being we also assist individuals
and family to gain access to and
determin eligibility for medical and
economic Assistance
programs this includes the supplemental
nutrition assistance program also known
as snap it includes the temporary
assistance for needy families program
known as
tanif a number of State supplemental
programs and we also determine that
eligibility for those programs as well
as
Medicaid we work very close closely with
our other divisions across the
department we have very strong
them we also work very closely with our
Community Partners who play an essential
services you will see me here before you
when there are needs to provide you with
information or respond to questions
about legislation regarding child care
family
assistance uh and employment
supports child support services are
typically heard by the children and
family law committee uh but if there are
questions of any of you you will
here you will also see our legislative
liaison his name is Brian Clark and I'm
sorry he couldn't join me here today
because he is actually participating in
an ad administrative appeals
hearing but with me today I do want to
introduce I'm pleased to introduce to
you the deputy director of the division
Tina
Cabana and I'm also pleased to introduce
one of the bureau Chiefs that you may
see from time to time when it's needed
which is Deborah sorley from the Bureau
assistance the another thing that I can
be of assistance to all of you for are
any inquiries from your own
constituents if you have individuals who
have questions or particular needs about
eligibility programs such as
Medicaid or other family assistance
programs where they just need help uh I
am available for you to provide you that
uh assistance and support for getting uh
what those individuals
need so feel free to out to me at any
time happy to answer any questions one
observation I have um as you may know I
I worked for the Department until
2019 and I think back then and I'm not
sure when it changed but child support
had was a division un itself at one
point and so was I think family
assistance so it's it's interesting to
see how the structure has changed over
the course of
time um that's correct any uh questions
from the committee I represent sen of
Edwards uh thank you thank you Mr chair
this may not be the right question for
Miss Hebert but um with the commissioner
gone I hope somebody can answer it by
the end of the meeting uh uh I've been
we've all been doing this many of us
have been doing this for many years and
occasionally we'll get um a constituent
uh I'll call it a complaint there's
probably a better word but sometimes you
get a constituent complaint and as
alleged legislator I don't want to get
involved in the personal information but
nevertheless I want to be able to uh do
my job of handing the issue off with you
know some specificity to just have the
department doing its its own independent
look into whether or not we did our job
right you know because it's a big
organization lots of people we don't do
everything perfect so occasionally it's
worth an independent relook what I would
like to know is as you know one of the
many legislators that may have
individual cases brought to us what is
the methodology we should use to to turn
this over to a responsible accountable
individual who could ensure that a
relook is done properly uh and again I
don't want personal health information
uh I just need to know at the end of the
day uh do we think we did this right and
if we didn't are we working to resolve
it I kind of need that sort of binary
answer thank you for the question
representative Edwards so I receive
inquiries from uh many uh frequently and
uh Mr Williams is also available and
receives some of those inquiries which
he often forwards to me uh Mr Litman
also receives inquiries that uh very
many of them get forwarded to me to
address
I would not provide you with detailed
information about those individuals my
role is to make sure that their needs
are addressed their questions are
answered and that they have the
information that they are looking for
that we take care of
them so for clarification regardless of
where in the department the complaint
might best be sourced you would be the
front door you and Mr Williams would be
the front door for the entire department
department and you will sort it out on
who should be looking into it we can
absolutely do that for you that's
outstanding thank you you're welcome
thank you anyway any other
much next individual is certainly no
stranger to this committee uh welcome
Henry
Litman between oversight committee and
this committee I see a lot of you and
you probably see more of me than you
uh U please put your microphone on
that's not true I'd be glad to be here
anytime thank you good to have you thank
you um just to open it up I'm Henry
Litman I'm the state's Medicaid director
I've been in that role now a little over
seven years um I report to an Landry who
is the associate commissioner um and um
I will introduce more of the team as I
go through uh the little slide deck I
have here um the walkway
piece um that's being handed out right
now is just so you have a reference if
you want to put it in one of your
notebooks or something so you know how
to get a hold of some of the key people
in the Medicaid
division
um so I think it it can be a little bit
confusing and um of like who to go to
For What and I I'm glad that Karen spoke
to that but
uh the um the Medicaid division provides
a
service which you probably be more
familiar to most of you which is the
like the health insurance part of of
what we provide the Medicaid Program um
the help what you would probably um
recognize as being the typical thing
when you have your own health
insurance we also provide um uh
Financial Technical Resources to support
other divisions and I'll I'll go into
that a little bit more in a moment but
just in terms of the sort of the heads
of the the Medicaid team are myself from
a program standpoint um I'm on slide to
um an Athena gagan who is um the
Medicaid Finance director um I've
included below that more probably for
division three kind of where you might
find some of the key um Financial unit
identifiers unique identifiers um in
terms of the policy team leads on slide
three
David chy uh is the Deputy Medicaid
director and um he'll there's a lot for
us to cover in the legislature at times
so either one of us I think can handle
any of your questions if we don't have
the answer we'll certainly come back
with it researched
um Olivia May is our director of
Medicaid Enterprise development and
really what that is is making sure that
both from the technology side and from
the different program areas that were
inte ating appropriately with like the
various divisions within the department
particularly as they use Medicaid
funds um Rob Barry I believe in the is
in the back here who is our Medicaid
legal
counsel um Dr Finny who's our Medicaid
medical director I think a lot of you
know her um a piece of news which is
good for her but not great for us is
that she will be retiring um in the
coming year here um and um Don uh Landry
who is our policy administrator I know
she is not here um Peg Clifford and Lisa
fan are our Pharmacy director and
pharmacy specialist the reason um you
know the Medicaid Program about 31% of
the expenditures within the Managed Care
Program are uh drugs and pharmaceuticals
and Gene therapies and um it's in the
seven years that I've been here it's
almost doubled in terms of of that and I
think in the the private sector you see
all these commercials on TV about all
these different drugs that are out there
there that's one element of it but there
are a lot of unique Gene therapies um
and cell therapies that are coming
available that can really um
particularly with children um deal with
conditions that change the trajectory of
what types of support they need in
life I don't know if pig or Lisa
here okay
um so uh slide four is a brief overview
of what we um what we do um we again
that we oversee the Managed Care
program that delivers the services and
the various service lines that are
available probably most notably is we
describe everything other than Medicaid
expansion which is the granted Advantage
Healthcare program is what we call the
standard Medicaid Program and then
there's the granted Advantage Healthcare
program
um we uh as I mentioned earlier we're we
we deliver those and oversee those parts
of the the program but we also work with
the other divisions for the Medicaid
services that they provide there there's
Financial eligibility which um Hebert's
uh division oversees the administration
of we help develop the policy
collaboratively with them to administer
that based on state and federal rules um
and then
secondly um with respect to eligibility
there's also for like long-term care
there's Al and Home and Community Based
Services there's also medical um uh
eligibility which um comes into play
with the division of long-term services
and support so uh Melissa Hardy who
heads that Karen and I work very closely
together um and making sure that the
Medicaid Eligibility the delivery of the
service are
accomplished
um I also included a slide five we had I
think members of division three and
maybe HHS may remember if you were here
uh last year that um there was some
discussion about how long of a
procurement we should would go through
uh in along with the discussion around
the reauthorization of Medicaid
expansion Grant Advantage Healthcare
program this is just highlighting the
new procurement um time frame that was
put in place and also um some of the key
features that were added to or or
revised as part of the the um the new
Managed Care
Program um slide
six are um policy matters that may be of
interest to either division three or HHS
that you'll probably hear about this
session one that is I think a carry
forward from last session is the
disproportionate share program and the
Medicaid enhancement tax program that uh
uh was one of the last items that was
dealt with last session but not not
fully um and I expect that we'll see
legislation in this session um Medicaid
to schools program is another program
that we administer um I know um we're
working in this next year to to uh
address how schools do their claiming
for um the Medicaid match um we believe
there's a greater opportunity in that
space which could help school districts
and local um communities um uh receive
more dollars for the services that they
provide that are Medicaid eligible um
the the method that New Hampshire is
using today sunsets federally in June of
26 so we applied for and received a
grant to help facilitate that transition
um and we're currently in request for
proposal uh uh we have proposals in that
we're evaluating for uh technical
support to help uh make that transition
so that schools can continue to claim
and hopefully be able to claim more for
the work that's being done there
um slide seven and eight are some um
views on enrollment I won't go through
it in detail but would say that one of
the key issues that we talked about last
session was the uh Federal Public Health
Emergency and continuous Medicaid
enrollment our roles grow to grew to
over 251,000 um today they're just over
184 they've been fluctuating between 182
and 184 over the last number of months
but uh
you may have heard of the concept of the
unwine which is
um when the public health emergency
ended we needed to um go back and this
was a big task and a big lift for Mrs
Hebert's division in terms of
reprocessing um eligibility um and doing
the verifications that go with that we
were one of the um first States one of
the first four states to be able to
begin that process and one of the
um and uh in terms of Pharmacy I think
um we um hope to see some legislation
this session about um how we can acquire
uh drugs within the Medicaid Program
more coste effectively than we do today
for um a cost savings which I hope would
be well received by division three um we
last session um implemented the Medicaid
provider rate increases which I've been
in healthare care in New Hampshire for
more than 30 years and they were the
largest increases that I think that
Medicaid has received in in my lifetime
in Medicaid and and in healthcare in New
Hampshire um but we've we've completed
that process um the legislature
obviously you all know that granted
Advantage was reauthorized last session
till till
2030 ad Del Dental was implemented last
session um we we really appreciate both
HHS and division 3 for their support and
working through the issues there um the
program I think is continuing to build
and and strengthened and we be happy to
provide uh periodic reports to the
committee and um and let you know how
we're
progressing um one of the waivers that
uh that the state has is called an 11:15
waiver um what that
does in it was renewed in July of
2024 um what was renewed component was
we inpatient substance use disorder and
impatient psychiatric care um the
federal government had an opportunity
for the state to draw a higher match on
those Services um with the understanding
that we would use the additional money
to uh maintain our community based and
strengthen our Community Based Services
which
um a lot of that has like our mobile
crisis service and I let Behavioral
Health talk about what what they're
doing but there have been a lot of
things that have been strengthened in
our mental health system to prevent
boarding and to um allow services to
happen within the community as opposed
to
institutional
um uh a new thing that was uh um if you
will generated from discussions with the
Department of Corrections
um was to be able to provide what we're
calling Community re-entry services for
adults what um what that initiative is
intended to do today there's a federal
exclusion for paying for any Services
behind uh the walls of a of a
prison um and except for an inpatient
admission at a hospital what we're what
we've been authorized to do here will be
something that will be of benefit to to
um our correction system both at a state
and county level
ultimately we'll be able to provide a
limited uh benefit for people who have
mental health disorders and substance
use disorders to make sure that um the
transition from behind the walls to the
community that there's a carefully
planned transition um operated through a
collaboration between the Department of
Corrections or syc to start with we
began January 1st and implementing this
at at those two levels and we'll be
moving to the counties we've been
meeting with each um County to
understand where they are but for
sentenc individuals when they're
released in the community that um
they'll have the medications that they
need um that they'll have their doctors
or other providers situated that they
can actually have some intake
appointments behind the wall so that um
the data that that uh the council and
state government has found about New
Hampshire a lot of recidivism in our um
County and state system are people who
have unmet Healthcare needs you know
they're they're hit the street they
don't they you know they need either a
psychiatric medicine or or a um medicine
to treat their substance use disorder
and if they don't have those things it
can end up in our emergency rooms which
is the most expensive place to do it um
and so um this initially came from uh
commissioner Hanks in terms of asking us
to apply for it and it went through the
process of approval to be able to apply
then also Congress um in
20123 for for youth um are requiring all
states to implement a limited benefit
program as well for individuals who are
children or um up to uh uh 21 or up to
26 if their form of foster care and it's
a little bit different than the adult
program where it's not just limited to
substance use disorder and mental health
conditions
but to make sure that um the types of
things that you'd want to see a child
have preventative screenings for ETC
that their health care needs are
identified before they leave the setting
that again that they're plugged into the
community system and an additional
feature is that there's Care Management
for 30 days after they leave that
setting um to be able to make sure that
not only were the things set up but
um we've also are working on
implementing from the last couple of uh
sessions the uh mnus Provisions uh that
were the douas and the lactation
Consultants we've already implemented
donor uh breast milk we having to work
with the office of professional
licensure on douas and
lactation um I'm going to skip the the
slides on um enrollment just jump to uh
the
slide that has the colorful picture of
pink and green here I see this page
number didn't make it on there um but uh
that is what I call our waiver wheel
this sort of describes the entire
Medicaid Program both what we oversee
directly within the division but also
the other parts of the department
whether it be in children's and youth
services Behavioral Health what have you
adult uh Services long-term services and
support but we we sort of work with
those divisions and getting these things
in place federally so that the services
can be claimed for under
Medicaid and lastly sometimes we'll
we'll talk about um different match
rates federally and this is just a table
on slide 10 of the different um match
rates that we get on different
Services um in um again I'll if you have
questions on the table be happy to take
them either today or any time um
Medicaid is a a complex uh program in
its details it's simple I think in you
know we basically are supposed to
provide a health insurance service under
the division of Medicaid services
through the Managed Care program after
that it gets a little deeper and thicker
but be happy to at any time either
oneon-one or or come to the committee
and provide additional
information thank you it's my
understanding and I think again going
back to my years in the department uh
Medicaid is roughly 70% % of the
Department's budget is that
correct um I think that is probably in
the neighborhood I know that the
Department's about 53% of the state
budget and I think we're probably at
least 50 60% of the Department's
budget I also noticed that um New
Hampshire Medicaid enrollment is fourth
smallest in the country is that
attributable to the to the unwind effort
or no um before the unwind we were
fourth smallest during the unwi when
we're fourth smallest and today we're
the fourth smallest
um the difference different states have
different Federal match rates for their
Medicaid Program federally like
Mississippi I think their match rate on
standard Medicaid is
82%
um New Hampshire's is 50% Massachusetts
is 50% both Maine and Vermont have a
little higher than New Hampshire and
it's based on a federal formula of the
economic status of the state as a whole
um and while New Hampshire is one of the
more affluent States we all know that
there are people who are not affluent in
the state um just to give you some
statistics New Mexico during the
pandemic had one in two people in that
state enrolled in Medicaid by comparison
New Hampshire was about one and five and
a half today we're about one and seven
but our neighboring states like Vermont
and and Maine are close to one and four
one and five um so we have fewer people
because of the economic status of the
entire population in New Hampshire um
which makes us the fourth smallest in
the country so that's a good thing I
would I would say yes yeah good great um
and we also have you know our
eligibility criteria are are as as
generous or more generous with respect
to um uh the various groups that we
covered great representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman thank you
for being here today I just wanted to
comment that uh
possibly as a an offshoot of um
representative Edwards comments or
questions um I have had a number over
the years of of constituents who have
had truly
emergent issues um of supplies they need
or care that caregivers that are
unavailable that were very desperate and
I try not to abuse the privilege but I
just want to say that any time I have
referred that to you you have
immediately found the right person to to
set it right and to ensure that that
constituent went on getting the services
they need and I'm very grateful to you
and your department for doing that so I
just wanted to note it thank you for for
saying so I I would add to that when we
were talking earlier about eligibility
there when the if you will the managed
care system isn't living up to what we
need it to do in a particular situation
and that's where my Division I I have um
two people that are
clinicians um who can help sort of size
up a situation clinically so I may be
working with uh Karen's team on that
issue because there may be elements that
are not just Financial or or criteria
but real medical needs and also Dr
ballad who's the medical director for
the department and the Medicaid Program
have access to to him as well and um you
know we try to be helpful there are
situations that are very concerning and
um at times and we we will jump on them
because we need
to representative Woods oh thank you uh
for Mr chair um um at the risk of
jumping down a rabbit hole which I don't
want to do but just a very superficial
comment do you have difficulties with
pbms and your Pharmacy
area um I would say that it's very
different than what the population at
Large
is experiencing because Medicaid um we
we have um a different relationship than
than the typical Commercial Insurance uh
with the pbms each of the mcos have
their own PBM but like all these issues
around like price transparency and
things like that we have th that issue
solved within the Medicaid Program we
get different discount levels as a
Medicaid Program um I think one of the
things that is happening out there that
that is similar to the rest of the
healthcare Market if you will is that um
narrower networks um Managed Care
organizations at one time had
relationships with all pharmacies and
now for example they may be with
Walgreens but not with um right8 or
whatever um and so we see that issue
also
um I think that uh um the the issue of
different um Financial factors playing
in uh with the transparency that we get
um we're not experiencing some of those
issues uh I think our our other issue I
guess that's common to the rest of it of
of the population and maybe somewhat
unique is all these Gene therapies for
rare diseases that come through and I
can tell you
that um for example one rare disease uh
that uh duchaine distrophy
um we've had since since that therapy
was a ailable um you know a few
instances where we've had to do it but
that therapy alone which actually
effectively cures Duane
distopy um in a way that they child has
a normal life costs 2.6
million um and so you know when I
started the program started working in
the program we'd have one or two of
these types of therapies come available
um each year last year 66 potential
therapies of that nature um were
available the the velocity of
breakthroughs and that the Medicaid
Program I think can experience more of
that because some of the individuals
that end up in Medicaid are because they
have rare conditions and so one of the
when if you go back to that
um page uh five one of the feature new
features in the program the second one
down was a High Cost Pharmacy risk pool
to make sure that the Managed Care
companies are better aligned with us in
terms of how we use these therapies
we've created a shared a greater sharing
of risk around those unique therapies um
and um you know we just initiated that
in September I don't uh but the the goal
of it is to make sure we have
appropriate utilization um that
there's um important followup that
occurs so that the therapy is selected
and used in the right instances and that
the the hospitalization and other things
that go around these therapies um done
well so that the investment that's being
made is is realized in a positive way
for the patient and the
state other
questions yes representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so you have a
nice chart here on the back about the
the federal match rates I would be
interested if you could just kind of
paint with a broad brush where we are
with our reimbursement rates on Medicaid
relative to some of our neighboring
states you know are we High are we low
middle thank you for the question um so
hb2 2023 um made a significant
investment in rates we were very low um
but with that uh um legislation I think
we were able to get a lot of um our
services in the uh Home and Community
Based Services and the long-term
Services competitive with other states
um and U in certain areas where we
Benchmark with Medicare I think where we
still have room to do better is with
with Physicians um and we we there were
increases there but um where we're
striving to do is to get to at least 80%
of Medicare um and in a number of places
we've achieved that um as part of the
the Met dish Arrangement that governor
senu and and commissioner um weer uh
worked on last session hospital
inpatient rates are now at Medicare type
levels um and under the Medicaid Program
we're not supposed to be generally
reimbursing more than Medicare so that's
why we're looking to get to 80 to 100
we're most of the way there except in a
couple
areas and is that in line with uh the
other states surrounding us pretty much
I think in terms of if I look at
Massachusetts Maine and and Vermont I
think we're probably
in the middle of all those I would say
at this point or or maybe a little bit
better than
that thank you representative
lante thank you I I'm new to this
committee and I'd like to get a big
picture understanding of Medicaid
funding and to understand the waivers
are we given an amount of money for
medic um I said Medicare but I meant
Medicaid that um is intended for the
insurance comp component and then we
apply with a waiver to direct that into
another program instead of leaving it in
the insurance component is that how it
works um great question but not not
quite so um it's a fe federal state
partnership um and so if you think of
the just a Pure medical insurance um
each person like you would in a um
private situation has a premium
associated with them we call it a
capitation amount and based on which uh
group they fall on on this chart like if
they're expansion population the feds
will give us 90% back if they're
standard population they'll give only
50% back if they're a CH child what we
call a chip program where where New
Hampshire provides a more generous level
of Eligibility the match is
65% so that that's how
the medical insurance Park gets paid for
in um if you kind of think about
Medicaid historically was just a
categorical program meaning like the
Aged the blind the disabled um
developmentally dis long-term care you
had to have a a categorical kind of
thing um to to qualify so the waivers
are intended to provide extra
services and they provided outside the
Managed Care Program um like nursing
home care as an example um the Home and
Community Based Services that are
long-term are outside the Managed Care
Program we provide home care for
short-term acute phases um within the
Medicare program again it works with
what services are delivered and build
for that the state picks up typically
their 50% share and the FEDS pick up the
other 50% so on a monthly basis or
quarterly basis we're accumulating all
these bills if you will going back and
or capitation payments and there's a
special form that we file with the
federal government to prove that we've
paid this amount of money and then they
send us money to match that
okay follow up though um yes just one
followup so by this chart here on the
last page um the granted advantage
that's a managed care that's
privatized um no it's delivered through
our same Managed Care organizations it's
just you know Congress federally had uh
in in encouraging states to offer it to
people who aren't don't fit a category
other than poverty um that they could
get insurance and obviously it was that
program I think 41 States now have
adopted it um you know there are you
know federally there are discussions
about what might happen in the future
there but New Hampshire is one of nine
states that has a trigger that if the
federal match changes that the program
would be signed Sunset and we also have
that larger um 7-year
reauthorization that uh the legislature
has moved from two years and two years
to five year and now a seven-year um uh
uh possibility to operate the program
without a
reauthorization okay thank
representative palazov and then
representative
Edwards
microphone uh thank you for taking my
question
I wonder if uh income cleff is an issue
for uh Medicaid and generally do you
have any ideas how we can address income
Cliff situation when a small increase in
income uh can cause a sudden loss of
public benefits uh that uh include
Medicaid or other benefits from
DHHS sure um there are other people can
speak and I think um Karen heit's
division of Economic Development they've
been working with Chris santinello the
ass commissioner there on the cliff
effect and there've been work that the
Department's done I've not been directly
involved in that but one of the things
we do do in our New Hampshire Medicaid
Program is that people who may go over
the cliff but who we recognize are
eligible for the ACA coverage on the
exchange coverage that we do make
referrals automatically um for that
where people have the opportunity to
consider if they qualif qualify or want
to uh buy into that
program representative Edwards um thank
thank you Mr chair um followup to
representative uh L montin I think um it
the the Medicaid issue is extremely
complex and uh We've not begun to
coordinate with Mr Lipman the division 3
uh presentation that Medicaid uh
delivers to us
but um but rather than deal with numbers
this time around I really want to teach
division 3 as much as we can about the
Medicaid Program and when we schedule
that with you I I'd like to open an
invitation to HHS for anyone wants that
wants to sit in on that because I I I
expect that to be more educational than
really Financial um so so that's just
one thing and to uh representative U
mlan on uh Medicaid reimbursement rates
uh division 3 uh looked at this pretty
seriously last budget cycle the
governor's budget had proposed something
like a uh 3% 4% I forget the exact
number of a increase to Medicaid
reimbursement and uh based on uh
testimony we received and looking at the
trend we saw from like 2010 to the the
current time that we had bled year over
year over year falling a little bit
further behind in U Medicaid uh equity
and and so uh we found the money uh last
budget to take another 10% and invested
around in the Medicaid services to try
to bring them back up to to be less less
competitive um this budget cycle I I am
having a very hard time imagining a
scenario where we're going to be able to
to do more than what the governor May
propose and we may not be able to even
do that so so if that's your issue it's
budget thank you other questions from Mr
good afternoon Mr chair and uh members
of the committee my name is Ellen Leo I
am the CEO of New Hampshire hospital and
I have some other individuals who are
here with me today who would also like
to introduce themselves uh but before we
do that I also wanted to mention that I
also support Glen Cliff home thank you
thank you I'm Brett Mason Chief
Financial Officer of New Hampshire
home and I am Cynthia babonis I am the
chief Community integration officer and
uh liaison for New Hampshire hospital to
the
legislature thank you
welcome thank you thank you for having
us um I just wanted to share some brief
information regarding New Hampshire
hospital and some of the things that we
have been working on in the last year or
so um and happy to take any questions
questions that you may have uh before we
do that I did also want to mention that
the chief medical officer Dr Jeff feder
also intended to join us today but was
unable to do so so he he sends his
regrets but I'm sure that there will be
an opportunity that you can see him um
at a future time in terms of a sort of a
high level review of New Hampshire
hospital we are the state's uh inpatient
acute Adult Psychiatric hospital we have
a capacity for 185 patients of which is
our current capacity um about a year ago
at this time our capacity was closer to
142 patients thankfully in the last year
we've been able to bring on our
additional beds to reach our full
capacity uh just last month actually in
December of
2024 um we have nine units they are all
approximately uh between 24 and 30ish
beds there is some variation there all
of them serve uh similar populations in
terms of serving the the most acutely
mentally ill individuals in the state we
do partner with uh what are called other
designated receiving facilities or drfs
in the state those tend to have a
capacity of between 10 and upwards of uh
14 to 16 beds those are more community-
based of which uh they go through a
certification process under
DHHS uh to re achieve that drf
designation and we partner with them to
try to ensure that the patients who uh
come to us for admission go to the
location that is most appropriate to
provide their care which would then
allow New Hampshire hospital to serve uh
the most acute individuals in the state
um in the past year we've also been an
integral part you you may be aware of or
heard of mission zero um and Care
traffic control uh Mission zero is the
Department's efforts to eliminate Ed
boarding of individuals who are awaiting
uh our level of care in the state of New
Hampshire I am um proud to say that on
four occasions recently we have achieved
a Quee of zero adults waiting in the
state um those have been through very
collaborative efforts of multiple
stakeholders um and many different areas
of the state but I mentioned care
traffic control uh CTC uh has really
been a driving force in being able to
make those accomplishments and minimize
some of the weight time that has uh
previously been the case for these
individuals CTC is part of our
admissions department at New Hampshire
hospital and in the past year they have
become really the central intake of all
of the Ia or involuntary emergency
admissions
uh orders throughout the state before
that it was parsed out to um basically
every single drf to kind of handle
independently um today actually the 16th
is the one-year anniversary of standing
up the care Traffic Control Department
um we are really proud of all the work
that they have been able to accomplish
and and celebrated them a bit today um
I'll hand it over unless there's
questions for me which I'm happy to
address uh to Cindy B bonus who will
share just a bit more
information M representative Weber I
just wonder if you would uh touch very
briefly on one of the things we have
heard a lot about in the past is not
only the issue of admissions but the
issue of timely discharge and I'd love
to hear just a little bit from one of
you about where you are with that
particular part of the puzzle thank you
representative that is a a wonderful
question and exactly the direction that
Cindy was going to go okay thank you
representative McKay had a question also
is that for M La point or it's it it's
connected I think uh to uh the question
you already have and that is about the
borders uh which
means that people get to New Hampshire
hospital through their local
hospital uh because of the lack of bed
capacity
those people are put into essentially a
room uh maybe a
TV uh there's no treatment for them and
sometimes they had been
staying uh in that hospital for days at
a time uh I understand that this has
changed and uh I would like everybody
here here to know that there has been
very
negative um uh attitude about the
hospital because of that it's not your
fault and I know that uh but I I've been
curious as to what you've done to I
problem so thank you representative
McKay and representative Weber um to
questions um we haven't quite gotten to
zero consistently in the queue and that
is directly related to how our beds are
currently utilized and so at New
Hampshire hospital um we do have quite a
few patients a percentage of our census
that are patients that are stable for
discharge and they more than 15 days
sometimes for months before we can
discharge them and that is related to um
resource shortages in the community at
lower levels of care and so to that end
one of the initiatives of mission zero
does include looking at the back door at
New Hampshire hospital um and reviewing
that population in collaboration with
the Community Mental Health Center
system and the division of Behavioral
Health and Nami um we have a work group
that is scheduled for um our first
meeting on January 30th to address those
issues to talk about what are the
systemwide res resources required in
order to bring these people out of the
hospital into the community um and even
process efficiencies that we can
Implement in order to um expedite
discharge planning and help our
patients be discharge from the hospital
as soon as they're clinically ready to
go other
questions seeing done oh Representative
grath no okay any other
good to see you again Miss tth T it's
been a few
years h no no now now it's on good
afternoon uh it's very nice to be here
my name is Meredith tus I'm the director
of the division of program quality and
integrity for the Department of Health
and Human Services and I am joined by
the director of our Bureau of program
quality Susan drown and our director of
our Bureau of program Integrity Tasha
Blanchard um not here today is the head
of our office of internal audit Teresa
Nero but I'll describe some of the
functions that she performs for our for
our division uh so our division is
getting somewhat tenured at this point
we're about four years old and we were
created in order to many of the
functions within the division already
existed but we were created in order to
bring those together Under One Roof so
that we could coordinate amongst each
other all of the support that we offer
across the department and strengthen
some of the support that we offer across
the department we are really a support
entity we support all of the other
programs within the department in one
way or another so originally it was
largely focused on Medicaid doing a lot
of quality work in quality metrics and
Medicaid Program integrity and also snap
for um our our SNAP program a lot of
support there but we've expanded over
the years so that we support programs
across the department both in in things
like data data analytics quality
performance metrics and also in
Integrity functions uh like audits
internal Audits and and external Audits
and reviews so that's a a high level
overview and then I'll ask uh Susan to
describe a little bit more detail in
what happens in the Bureau of program
quality sure good afternoon Susan drown
I'm the director of the Bureau of
program quality and it's our bureau's
mission to provide data driven support
across the entire department um and
that's with the aim of informing
decision and policym as well as
providing support with quality
management and performance Improvement
activities so we do that by leveraging
the skills of our staff across five work
units we have health services assessment
contract quality management data
analytics and Reporting Medicaid quality
program and then substance misuse
prevention and evaluation and just
briefly two of the primary um activities
that we do is for Medicaid Care
Management data we do data collection
and reporting to ensure that our New
Hampshire citizens who are receiving
Medicaid are have access to quality
services and then we also work across
the department to provide standardized
methods of contract quality management
um with regards to active contract
management and through that we also look
at um performance metrics uh those areas
that we have contracted for that are
desired outcomes and the standards and
for those areas that fall below that we
help develop quality improvement plans
standards hi my name is Tasha Blanchard
and I'm as Merida said I'm the director
of the program could you speak up a
little
more um I'm the director for the program
integrity and there are six units on
under the program Integrity but all of
the units do reviews and
investigations under the different
programs within
DHHS we also are considered subject
matter experts in as far as compliance
goes and Regulatory and we assist many
of the program areas when they're
developing their new programs their new
um rules or whatever to ensure that
there is compliance in those programs
and benchmark Mar s that are manageable
and accountable we also assist with many
of the programs in any kind of Financial
reviews they may have of their vendors
their providers and contractors so um we
make and we also make sure that the
programs are doing what they're required
we manage a lot of the federal audits
that come in and we we work very hard to
make sure that ghhs addresses corrective
action plans and that we fix the
problems that are found in any of those
Audits and we've done a very good job in
that that we've reduced the single audit
findings from about 14 down to four and
so we're very proud of that effort that
we've put into that is the investigation
junit still under you yes it is and we
um we are under the 10% backlog as of
last month wow how did you ever do that
a lot of hard work sure I have no doubt
we have incredible uh leader in that
unit now uh Lindsay bibo and her she and
her staff believed that they could do it
and we didn't voice any disbelief and
they did it it was it was really a
remarkable achievement how many
investigators out there now I think we
have seven now and two and and two
claims and two claims okay yeah right
that's right uh so the office of
internal audit um is headed up by Teresa
Nero who couldn't be here this afternoon
um but do a lot of uh internal it's
internal reviews exclusively so um Can
internally look for management at um you
know issues of compliance or efficiency
Effectiveness whatever kind of
management review needs to be done um if
there are um they take in referrals for
fraudulent and unethical conduct across
the Department per our fraudulent and
unethical conduct policy um they would
do an investigation that's not Personnel
investigation they would just do an
investigation for that fraudulent or
unethical behavior um they also work to
beef up internal controls across the
department that includes policies
procedures Communications training um
all that kind of stuff but it's really
internally focused so so you might think
of like an ombudsman's office they do
things with external stakeholders and
they can do reviews from external
stakeholders this is just internally
focused okay thank you any questions
representative Edwards
thank you Mr chair um just tell us I
think it's it's a little over four years
now since I think we first started
talking and I've been treed by your
program from the very first uh
presentation I think we talked about um
the um um the capability and limits in
your capability of your office and as I
remember them briefly it was that you
are focused as you must be at coming up
with benchmarks and quality measures for
our contracts but at the time you had
not had the capacity to take a look at
uh departmental internal
benchmarks uh and so we had a discussion
about it and I think please come up with
a 10-year plan so that we can have
benchmarks for all our departments you
know if you can't measure it you can't
assure that you're doing it right right
and so um so that was four years go I'm
just wondering if you remember and if
you could give us an update on where you
guys are at having bench marks for our
departments so sorry I have a large
light in the way when I'm trying to see
you um but I also want to use the
microphone so everyone can hear so a
couple things one um yes so the contract
quality management unit which was
probably non-existent the first time we
had that conversation is now up and
running and actually staffed with three
individuals so they are working across
the department with program areas to
really beef up the way we write our
contracts and the the way we think about
our contracts the way we write our
contracts and then the way we manage our
contracts so that we can consider those
kinds of performance metrics which
really though they exist in a contract
they are our program intended
performance metrics right they're the
deliverables we need as a department in
order to be sure we're accomplishing our
strategic goals um so that is that is up
and run and they're starting to work
with various program areas across the
department um and create all kinds of
templates and tools that can be
leveraged even when they don't have the
capacity to work directly with with
someone
um as far as more department-wide you
know programmatic goals I think one
thing you and I talked about was kind of
inputs in and then outputs that you get
from that and that from a department
perspective is extraordinarily difficult
because as we discussed we have hundreds
of pieces of leg legislation that impact
US every year and those require all of
our inputs that are doing other things
to incorporate then these new uh these
new goals and and things that we have to
accomplish and so then the things that
you were measuring are either no longer
being measured or you need to measure a
whole bunch of new things because things
change so so rapidly so um the the
metrics that we have prioritized are the
ones in the commissioner's road map and
those metrics include a few different
areas and that way we can link them with
our strategic goals our our budgetary
inputs and where we're trying to get
between us and our contractors at the
same time and so those are split into
three different areas um we've got kind
of internally focused things uh
investing in people and culture we've
got um our Our Community Focus so that's
where the contracts come in in terms of
programmatic outcomes and then we've got
uh improving customer service is the
Third Leg of that road map and that's
improving things like um
like our like our Contracting process so
that the people we are Contracting with
can see those improvements so there's
there's sort of functional goals in
there and then there's also uh uh
programmatic strategy goals in in
including like improving the health of
women and children that are in there and
those have specific targets and
deliverables in that road map that are
that are attached to numbers specific
numbers
y
followup all I i' I've always been
impressed with your way of thinking
about this and what you're doing and so
so once again I kind of way confident
that you're doing it right I love the
idea that you prioritize the
commissioner's strategic road map uh
what what I think I'm going to ask you
to do is to bump you to the front of the
division three heing line so that you
can walk through the road mapap and tell
us what benchmarks or measures uh we
should be anti ipating as we hear the
rest of the budget and I'm sure the
commissioner and and Nathan white have
that in mind um but I will definitely
bring it just and as my LBA to do that
oh great okay thank you other
questions seeing
you and next up is Melissa Hardy who is
he long to long-term supports and
services
here we go there we go my husband's it
he would have told me to unplug it and
plug it back in see if it works so thank
you John um good afternoon I'm Melissa
Hardy I'm the division director for
long-term supports and
services um our division with ltss
promotes the health and well-being of
people and their families um throughout
the lifespan so you hear me talk briefly
about services that we provide um to
Children um youth adults and people who
are aging the ma um the majority of our
programs are focused on Home and
Community Based Services so providing
Services through provider agencies that
allow um individuals and families to
remain um at home or in the community
that they prefer to reside
in um in our division we have three uh
distinct bureaus first I'll start with
uh what was formerly known as the Bureau
of elderly and Adult Services which is
now uh rebranded and named as the Bureau
of adult and Aging
Services we changed the name um in July
of
2024 and we moved away from the word
elderly um when we talk about people who
are aging and I have a little pin here
that we all wear it says aging
everyone's doing it um and and looking
at research and um you know working with
our partners along with the state plan
on Aging the word elderly has a negative
connotation to it and we're all aging um
so we were happy and proud to to adopt
that language change for our Bureau um
and again that was in July of 2024 and
we know New Hampshire is an aging State
it's projected um by 2030 for over
onethird of the state um to be over the
age of 65 so um we're really looking at
shifting how aging is perceived in the
the culture of the Aging
Services um in in hb2 uh we were uh
given an investment in the system of
care for healthy aging that I think a
lot of you were um a part of and and so
thank you for that um which established
an implemented a comprehensive and
coordinated system of care for for
healthy aging and enables adults and
adults with disabilities to have
meaningful Choice um in the ability to
receive the care when and where they
want it um so that is on part in part of
um the commissioner's road map um that
you'll see that she presented on earlier
uh as one of our strategic
priorities also in the Bureau of adult
and Aging Services we um have programs
and services that we fund provider
agencies to provide on our behalf um
you're prob most of you are aware of our
Medicaid waiver program under aging and
adult Services um the CFI progam program
the choices for Independence waiver it's
a Medicaid waiver for individuals who
meet nursing home level of care but
prefer to receive their care in the
community so we uh administer that
program uh along with our case
management agencies and provider
agencies through the Medicaid
waiver we also provide funding for
nutrition programs so Meals on Wheels
and congregate meal programs um we in
2024 we funded meals for over 2. uh we
funded over 2.4 million meals in the
state of New Hampshire to over um 15,000
um Unique
Individuals um some some interesting
feedback from nutrition services and I
think one that hits me when I see it is
that 41% of people who receive Meals on
Wheels say the Meals on Wheels driver is
the only person that they will see all
week so that's very important you know
it's more than just a meal delivery
service it's really uh it can be a
welfare check on folks um and they're
really eyes on um to the people that we
serve so it's a real um uh value ad
service for
us another um uh service that we provide
funding for with our um service
providers is transportation um so we
funded um about over um 120,000
individuals with Transportation routes
throughout the state
and that was you know transportation to
medical appointments grocery shopping
good um I think as Henry and Karen
alluded to the Bureau of adult and Aging
Services also provides medical
eligibility for nursing facilities and
um the choices is for Independence
waiver program so we um administer the
medical eligibility process for
Medicaid we also have um aging and
disability Resource Centers known as
service link uh we have um 13 local
offices throughout the state that
provide person centered option
counseling information and referral
services um Family caregivers support
programs um kind of serving as a central
hub for information for people um who
are looking for services for um adults
and people who are
aging and finally in um the Bureau of
adult and Aging Services we have adult
protection um so we promote the safety
of vulnerable adults and identify and
meet the needs of vulnerable vulnerable
adults to decrease um the incidence of
self- neglect and Mal treatment so um in
2024 um Adult Protective Services served
about 6,100 vulnerable adults in need of
exploitation um the the second Bureau I
want to speak of is our Bureau of
Developmental services or BDS where we
partner with um 10 area agencies local
area agencies as well as um Medicaid
service providers who are enrolled in
Medicaid to provide Home and Community
Based Services for individuals um with a
developmental disability um and also
individuals with an acquired brain
disorder that is also on the
commissioner's road map as system
strengthening for um the developmental
systems
services in in BDS in the the Bureau of
Developmental Services we have three um
Home and Community Based waivers so
again we have the developmental
disabilities waiver serving individuals
um who have a a diagnosed um
developmental disability we serve
individuals on our acquired brain
disorder waiver and we also have in home
supports waiver which um supports
children living in the community with
disability again I mentioned our our 10
area agencies so we have a contract with
our 10 area agencies who are really our
eyes on in the backbone of the
developmental Services System um they uh
provide person centered planning um have
been around for I think over 30 plus
years um and um are really a partner
with the Department in a lot of the
change that has happened over the the
past five years in the Bureau of
Developmental
Services we also have over a 100
Medicaid enrolled community- based
providers that provide um services to
individuals such as case management or
Service Coordination um assistive
technology non-medical Transportation
RIT um Community integration services
that you know help people achieve more
Independence in all aspects of their
life and then lastly um we have the
Bureau of family centered services so uh
the B the family of Center Services
identifies and coordinates supports that
assist children from birth to 21 years
old um who have or at risk for a chronic
medical condition disability or special
Health Care need and their
families um so that Bureau really helps
New Hampshire families and professionals
with health information care
coordination um Family Support you've
probably heard of early intervention
services so for for children uh birth to
three um includes intake evaluation uh
family uh support plans and transitions
for any um kids who might be showing a
developmental um delay um with their um
developmental milestone so we coordinate
that service as
well um my Bureau Chiefs weren't able to
be here today but I do want to introduce
Melissa nemith who is in the um in the
gallery over here she is our legislative
liaison for the Bureau of Developmental
services and the Bureau of family
centered services so I'm happy to take
any questions um in what I handed out it
was contact information for key people
in my division um so please feel free to
reach out that way as
well any
questions I don't see any great thank
Fox the division of Behavioral
Health so good afternoon at the risk of
um blowing too much of the speakers I'm
trying to um because I know that I can't
hear back there so I'm hoping you can
hear me um by being right on top of this
mic com in hot um so I am asking Jenny O
Higgins to join me she is our um
division's legislative liaison so I'm
Kya Fox I'm the director of the division
for Behavioral Health our division
oversees community-based services for
substance misuse Mental Health Services
and homeless services and so you I
you're most likely have or will be
approached by people in your community
who need these services and there are
many dozens of organizations that we
contract with who provide those services
so your Community Mental Health Centers
your peer support centers your um
homeless uh shelters all of those fall
within our division we have a makeup and
I don't expect you to remember any of
this so I'm going to I know you've
gotten a lot of materials today so we're
happy to provide any information that
you feel like you need today or at any
point uh during the legislative process
and if you um also knowing that you have
constituents who will be seeking you out
about these services so um we have a
policy unit of which Jenny is a member
and then we have four bureaus that
address those issues so we have the
Bureau of drug and alcohol Services the
Bureau of Mental Health Services which
addresses the adult population the
Bureau of children's Behavioral Health
which obviously addresses uh children's
needs and then the Bureau of homeless
Services which within the last couple
years has joined our division because of
the uh what leads to um someone being
unhoused and um recognizing that our
services are so critical to their
supports and um you're going to hear a
lot of buzzwords over the next six
months you're going to hear a lot of
things that are referred to um they all
are made up of those Services um but we
use as our blueprint our 10-year Mental
Health Plan and that's available online
be happy to provide it to you and get a
link to you um and that was established
in 2019 it's still very relevant today
and we have done uh an incredible job
with the support of the the governor and
with the legislature to bring those um
recommendations and those services
online um so that includes New Hampshire
rapid response which is mobile crisis
which is available in your communities
we also have a children's system of care
which is in statute and that also lays
out what's expected to have a robust
children's
system we uh appear you'll see uh
particular priorities that appear in the
commissioner's road map and we uh
partner with um New Hampshire hospital
and other uh providers that you that
were mentioned by Ellen Le Point in her
discussion about n Hampshire hospital
what I thought I would do um I'm going
to have Jenny just explain her process
she is the front face you're going to
see her um and if you don't see her in
your committee room you'll see her in
the hallway um probably texting me or or
um s you know doing some work um and
then we'll also introduce the other
members of our team who um are among
those who will be called upon to uh
you hi there I'm Jenny O Higgins I'm our
legislative liaison and Senior policy
analyst in the division for Behavioral
Health um I work very closely across our
policy unit with our director and Deputy
as well as all of our Bureau Chiefs
throughout the whole session responding
to providing information and and and
weighing in on bills and completing all
of our fiscal analysis Etc so I'm
absolutely available to you for
questions throughout the session um and
able to get back with those folks that
are closely tied to the programming and
find out questions around how those
things are implemented or funded so
happy to answer any of your questions
throughout the
session thank you and as I said I have
um a a few people here who um I asked to
join we have a couple of new Bureau
Chiefs um so this is new to them um but
we wanted to make sure they're not new
to the work I can assure you of that but
we wanted to make sure that they got a
sense of how you conduct your business
and um they are the subject matter
experts that Jenny will be leaning on to
come in and provide information so I'll
just ask them to stand and wave so we
have Daryl Tenny who is the bureau chief
Health we have Carolyn Lewis who is the
bureau chief for mental health
services and um Jennifer sabbin who is
the state opioid response program
director that's something I know that
you all have heard about and experienced
in your communities and she SE oversees
all the programming around that um
Federal
Grant and I'm hoping I didn't forget
anyone apparently not so with that um
again we're here uh to help you help
people and um we' be happy to answer any
questions that you may have again today
and in the future thank you
representative damus thank
you thank you for me take taking my
question it's very simple do you have
contact information um or a sheet that
you could pass out to us
so I'm hearing from John Williams that
do great and again um some of the
resources and materials are available
online and can be made available uh to
you um as requested and as
needed representative
chairman uh what I'm going to say is
should not be viewed as a criticism
of the
department uh I have a constituent more
than one actually that called me uh this
particular person was in New Hampshire
hospital for more than three months
which tells you was a very severe case
because the actual time is 3 to five
days something along that he was
referred to a mental health
center uh he's been
getting good care and
medication he feels
tremendously the need for
counseling that there is no counseling
for him in that middle Health
Center
and
the I I hear this
often in in terms of not only midal
Health Centers he he was referred to
three private groups all of whom said we
can't do a thing for you for at least
six
months now I'm I'm sure you hear this
every day there's nothing new about it
what I'm concerned about is there
anything we can do to help out uh to
provide
services I
know uh I I'm just too old to go back
and do that kind of work again if I wish
I could uh but is is there anything we
can do for you uh to help these
individuals who at the present time are
not getting care because there isn't uh
sufficient Personnel to provide that
care so thank you very much for sharing
that um personal um interaction that
you've had with a constituent and we do
hear that that is an area that needs
Improvement access to care is so
critical especially um as people are
seeking it and so we're doing multiple
efforts we have found as you heard in
the mission zero discussion that it
isn't just one solution it's multiple
Solutions and so Workforce and not not
just looking at the workforce in um
having it um people go to school get you
know certain degrees and then enter the
workforce and we all get a little
frustrated because that takes time we're
looking at expanding the workforce and
so who can provide services who can be
the person that is able to support
someone in the community and it may not
always need to be a clinician it can be
a peer and it can be community and how
do we build communities to be able to
support someone um who's in need of
those services so you are going to hear
a lot about this in the upcoming session
um there are multiple bills to address
this um but we we totally understand and
um anyone who um is in our system
deserves to have those services
available when they need them and it is
all of our jobs to make that happen
thank you other
good
afternoon good afternoon Ruben Hampton
director office of Health Equity if you
could speak a little louder and bring it
a little
closer good afternoon ribbon Hampton
director office of Health Equity thank
you um my name is Elizabeth Maynard and
I um am with the an attorney with the
office of legal and Regulatory services
the mission of the office is to help
identify and mitigate Health disparities
for all constituents in particular uh
those from low-income backgrounds those
with
disabilities and uh racial
ethnic gender and uh other
minorities we do a lot of work to help
ensure folks have Equitable access to
the benefits and services that the
department
offers there are a few different
functions of the office in particular
there's communication access we manage
the services for the Department that
includes interpretation uh translation
we provide training internally
externally vendors Partners
uh help them with their
plans help them get set up to provide
services to
their own
clients and we also
provide support and community outreach
and
engagement there are different grants
and programs within the department that
may need to reach out to specific
populations that we can assist with so
we can connect them with some of those
specialized
populations there are others that need
education and aren't aware of all the
latest information on some of the
benefits and services the department
offers so we help facilitate those
conversations as well we provide
training and resources on providing more
culturally appropriate care so they can
be more effective with the different
clients and populations that they work
with and help troubleshoot different
problems we receive Outreach on whether
those are individual clients or other
fellow state workers from different
departments who uh are in need of
assistance we also have the refugee
program that runs the office as well so
we administer a few different grants and
work with service providers to uh ensure
the refugees and other o eligible
clients who come over are able to uh
is your office relatively your division
relatively new I don't remember it from
past this office didn't have a director
for two years between 2020 and 2022 so
that could be why I joined in February
2022 and I think missed this event prior
so it could have felt like four years
okay and how big a division is is your
section 11 currently 11
thank you representative Edwards uh
thank you we we've met several times to
talk about uh your programs and uh I I I
I want I want to just uh help your your
program out and and help the people in
New Hampshire understand what your
program does and what I think it's
important for people to understand what
your program doesn't do I I think um the
word Equity has become um politically
suspect in many groups uh and so with
that in your title uh I I I want to make
sure that um we're clear on on what you
all are doing I I think it's absolutely
appropriate and imperative that we
know our state
demographics and that we're seeking ways
to ensure that all of the demographics
in our state have good strong equal
access to health care and that you're
helping to identify
barriers uh that may get in the way of
that equal
access uh and you're trying to eliminate
them education and
communication what so that's what you're
doing I believe what you are not doing
and it's important for people to
understand this is I I don't think you
guys are looking
to disproportionately Advantage any
demographic to get Superior or frontof
the line kind of care you're you're
looking to make sure there's equality in
the access is is is that fair to
say I think that is fair to say
representative okay follow up follow up
okay and then the other part of this
that I think is in your VIN diagram is
uh there's a lot of concern about the
state spending money on um ill the term
that's used usually as illegal
immigrants and talking to Mr Litman and
you and others uh I believe that you
have a strong program where you're
making sure that any you know Refugee or
any non us-born
um um patient is run through an
eligibility system to make sure they're
here legally and that they're getting
the services that between the federal
government's uh authorizations and
permissions and our own that uh we we
are not giving out um health care
benefits to um the Goda ways the people
who really ought not to be in the
country and who are hiding so so to turn
that into a question do do you think
that
um it would be fair to tell the people
of New Hampshire that we have strong
programs to make sure that those foreign
born people who are in New Hampshire are
receiving authorized care and if they're
not here legally in a legal status that
we have control mechanisms to prevent
services as you noted the refugee
program is a federally funded and
administered program so there are
specific uh regulations on who can be a
client uh all refugees are vetted
overseas The Limited categories of
others who can receive benefits uh also
have specific requirements all have
legal status to be here so so again I
think you're confirming that we're
positively giving care to those who are
authorized under various programs the
question is actually the negative of
that we're also ensuring that those
people who are not here under a legal
category are bented or blocked or dis uh
disadvantaged to receiving care that
they're not authorized to we're not
spending money on on the Goda
ways and I hopefully that's a yes kind
of a simple yes for the our program
specifically
am other
questions seeing none okay thank you
you and last but certainly not least uh
Melissa St SE was scheduled but filling
I can represent to this group that
during my uh law school education I did
not make a living moving furniture but I
did the best I could just now uh for the
record oh that's right this is not a
legislative hearing but I just wanted to
thank you and chairman McDonald and also
um chairman Edwards for your
participation today your attention over
the last two hours and now going on
about 10 minutes is really appreciated
uh Melissa Sint here uh could not be
here today so I am here just to identify
some of the programs that she's involved
with under Melissa's umbrella as our
chief legal officer um my myself John
Williams uh I theor dor of legislative
affairs and I fall under her umbrella uh
and also with me today
is my name is Katherine burnhard I'm the
Department good afternoon I'm Dorian
shley I am the manager of the Bureau of
Licensing and certification I think I've
met many of you in the past and I'm sure
I'll see you
again and onto my right my name is
Danielle warboys I'm the attorney for
the Bureau of Licensing and CER
ification and so under the legal and
Regulatory services that U Melissa
ministers we have our administrative
rules unit we have the office of General
councel we have
legislation um and we also have our uh
wonderful licensing folks and our
privacy officers so you can tell that
there's a lot of activity that happens
within our legal regulatory unit um and
so I just wanted to thank you for the
opportunity for this wonderful meeting
and greet that we had today uh I in in
my role and capacity as legislative
director very similar to what Jenny O
Higgins had mentioned to as the
legislative leison for the division for
Behavioral Health uh I'm involved with
helping coordinating legislative
activity for the entire department but I
work with many many wonderful people uh
the legislative Liaisons are subject
matter folks they're people who are
attorneys like myself uh who do an
incredibly thoughtful job working with
you uh you're very thoughtful in what
you do the questions you ask and the
opportunity to be a resource to you uh
on areas of uh developing policy for
very important uh things that you heard
about today um the other thing that uh I
do is I do work along with Nathan white
if you don't know Nathan uh you should
he is our Chief Financial Officer he's
identified on that wonderful wonderful
one page that we have with the contact
information uh but he's somebody who
works very closely with division three
but he also works with our legisla
Liaisons and myself uh and developing
the fiscal analysis on big bills that
come before your committee those bills
that have greater than 10
$110,000 in fiscal impact and that's a
sizable portion of a job that we do that
you don't see here that we're doing back
in the office um we also many of us work
later at night just like you do getting
the work done that needs to be done and
then finally it is probably one of my
most pleasurable parts of my job is
getting an opportunity to work with you
on on constituent inquiries uh I will
say as uh over the years it is something
that um is very rewarding when I see
your constituents uh coming in our
Direction and we're able to help them
understand the process and get those um
um whatever services that they were
eligible for so it's been a long day and
I really do appreciate your attention
the good news for you is you're not on
division 3 because they do the budget
and many times they're here till well I
can tell you I've seen the sunrise uh uh
at division 3 during the committee
conference on the budget and I just
really want to thank you and again
chairman McDonald and chairman um
Edwards for this opportunity today uh my
parting comment is the materials that
were provided to you uh and we need to
get a few more out to you is are going
to be provided electronically to you all
the materials today both to the Health
Human Services LD Affairs committee as
well as house finance division 3 uh
you'll be receiving those materials
either later today or first thing
tomorrow uh with that we're looking
forward to the opportunity of working
with you I must say uh over the decade
and a half almost two decades of doing
this this committee has always turned
out to be just a wonderful committee to
work with it's very collaborative under
the leadership over the years and I just
want to again uh emphasize we're just
looking forward to
2025 thank you attorney Williams just to
clarify Ln RS Licensing and Regulatory
Services that's what it stands for that
is what it stands for and you you and
what's amazing you have a packet it's a
56 page packet of 12 font size acronyms
for the Department each of you have
received that and that'll be part of
your materials that we received today
one of the things that we we work on in
terms of clear communication with the
committee is I do ask my legislative
leaon to refrain as much as possible
from the use of acronyms because it is a
very acronym Rich world we live in I was
favorably impressed that I didn't hear I
don't think one Acron acronym said by
one of our staff testifying before you
today but if somebody does testify and
start using a lot of acronyms you either
have your secet Dakota ring or ask them
to slow down and actually explain what
that acronym stands
for thank you Tony Williams I want to
thank you for setting this up today and
your coordination efforts and and making
this happen it was very
helpful again thank you to everyone in
the department for coming and um yeah
I wonder what work we're doing in the
area of improving licensing reciprocity
especially in nursing field and other
and also whether and to what extent
we're doing anything to uh on on the
area of Licensing
to bring more retired nurses out of
retirement given the short that we have
only in
if I could just address and I'll have U
um Miss shley write so that the public
can can hear the the two questions that
were raised is what what is the
department doing around reciprocity on
lure uh I'm going to just feel that one
very briefly the executive department
administration committee uh they have
the office of professional lure in
certification that license a multitude
of boards including the board of
medicines which includes Physicians uh
they also um administer the Board of
Nursing Board of Pharmacy see a whole
bunch of boards that are out there so I
would suggest um to the representative
that I would be more than happy to get
them into contact with the executive
director um um over with um the office
of professional licensure to talk about
what they're doing around reciprocity
because that's beyond the scope of our
agency's uh work we we don't author we
do not license um um individuals uh uh
professionals but we do um license
facilities and that's where I'm going to
segue it over to dine Shan
Ley so thank you for the question it was
an important question to make the
distinction that the bureau that um I'm
speaking on behalf of is um for
facilities for all Health Facilities
nursing homes we do the um but not the
individuals so we'll get that
information
yes there was another
question oh it was another you said this
here oh okay I'm
sorry representative mlan did you have
something yeah one
sec I noticed on on the contact sheet I
I was unaware of this position um you
have a position of hitsman and office of
long-term care armman I was unaware of
those positions could you maybe let us
know what their roles are and and you
know the scope of their powers kind of
thing yes um and if Melissa Saint SI
were here she would have not have missed
because under her umbrella also falls
the administrative Appeals Unit as well
as the um budman's office the office of
um budsman is statur created it is under
the Department of Health and services
but they're specifically designated to
be independent from the Department in
other words they're enabled to provide
um Services uh to do investigations uh
uh individuals who have constituent
inquiries or concerns over Services can
certainly go to the ombudsman's office
uh for assistance um and they serve a
very important role for advocating on
behalf of citizens of New Hampshire
based upon concerns they may have with
the department now with that said
represent mlan I need to make a
distinction there is a second
ombudsman's office it's called the
long-term care ombudsman's office and
Sue buckon is the long-term care um uh
on budsman they go by olito here we go
initial I mean acronyms but um by the
office of long-term care on budsman and
they are specific to the area of
long-term care so we're talking over in
dorin um area that there's an overlap so
I'm going to turn it over to Dorene to
talk to you about that other um busman's
office and how her um her uh folks who
work on lure deals with the um bussman's
office thank you so our we have a
certification team we are the state
agency for the federal um CMS um and we
work very closely our in our residential
settings nursing homes and um assisted
living facilities with suckon and her
team to make sure we're looking at
investigations or
allegations from the lens of the
facility and is the facility compliant
with rules and regulations the
ombudsman's office is working from the
lens of the resident or the patient
making sure that their needs and their
are being met um so we'll often
collaborate from both lenses to make
sure that um every individual is being
served in the manner that they have have
delus thank you Mr chair this is more of
a statement nice to see you
again um as far as the Ombudsman I I
probably shouldn't even direct it to you
but to representative mlan I was in need
of the Ombudsman and had found out about
that office years ago and as a as a
private citizen at the time uh one of my
relatives I feel was not being treated
well and had broken ribs and a broken
arm and so I called the office of the um
budsman because I didn't know how to
deal with it with the facility and then
that they took that out of my hands and
the utsman went in without warning and
just checked on that patient and um I
think the that was amazing and the
treatment that my
relative received after that was much
much other
questions I don't see any okay thank you
very
much and we do have one more speaker uh
we have Rebecca sky from the state
and may Mr Mr chairman uh and and just
so you know Sue Buxton is on one of the
members of the Commission on Aging so
there's an awful lot of interweaving of
people's hats and rolls and all of this
yes uh and I work down the hall from um
that office and they do amazing work for
a very vulnerable
population um so thank you for your time
today my name is Rebecca Sky I'm the
executive director for the New Hampshire
State Commission on Aging uh the
Commission on Aging was created during
the 2019 legislative session uh with a
primary charge to advise the governor
and the legislature on issues related to
aging largely in response to our
dramatically changing demographics to a
notre age
population so um we are are here to be
of service to you if you ever have a
question about a particular policy point
and its impact on all of us as we age
please reach out to the commission if we
don't have if we haven't already
researched the answer to the question we
will dive in and research it's a 26
member commission um of of very engaged
people we have um actually we have one
state senator two three state reps 13
people appointed by the governor and
eight state agencies represented on the
commission
so um diving more into why the
commission was created um you you have a
one it's two-sided but it's one piece
piece of paper um it's the last two
pages of our annual report and on the
side that has the graph that's on at the
bottom corner says page 40 um uh you
will see um data from the I think it's
uh the department uh it's the office New
Hampshire office of planning and
development within the Department of
Business and economic Affairs develop
this data making uh population
projections from 2020 to
2050 um and this is for the population
aged 65 plus if you notice the dashed
green line that's the 85 Plus population
and as all of you know government is
created by people policy makers such as
yourself uh for the people in response
to who the population is and so that is
why the commission is here to help our
um all of you um be responsive to these
demographic changes that are happening
in our
state so the four-page handout the one
that looks like this is the executive
summary of our annual
report um on the first page of the of
this executive summary uh the commission
urges policy makers uh to see our
growing older adult population for the
opportunity all of us are if you look
around this room that's
us um page two names the four
overarching priorities the commission
has identified for the state in response
to changing
demographics we need to strengthen our
systems of care for healthy aging prior
to 2023 the last time the system of
services for older adults was
significantly addressed was actually in
1998 uh with legislation Under the
Umbrella of shaping tomorrow's future uh
shaping tomorrow's choices the work done
during the last budget cycle uh to
establish the system of care that
Melissa Hardy uh referenced needs to be
built upon during this and upcoming
legislative sessions one item in
particular from uh House Bill 2 from
2023 was a call for a Medicaid rate
study of Home and Community Based
Services and for the upcoming budget
proposal to reflect changes based on
that study hopefully you'll have an
opportunity to review that
soon um we also call for an effort to
grow our Direct Care Workforce that
provides long-term services and supports
not only in our nursing facilities but
in in our communities and in people's
homes and Under the Umbrella of
advancing age-friendly policy systems
and environments the commission calls
for efforts to create age inclusive
workplaces to engage our older workers I
think it was a mentioned just now how do
we bring back our our retired nurses we
need them um we also uh talk about
ensuring that our new hous hous in
builds are smart builds and that they
are they are age ready with no barrier
entries and bed and baths on the first
floor um and that we Foster Civic
engagement and make efforts to address
social isolation among um among many of
the other items that are named in our
full report uh finally we call for the
development of a long-term vision for
change a ro map of policy considerations
to create the future that we seek many
of the changes need incremental changes
to build to them
um we have branded this plan the agw
plan uh HW NH plan excuse me uh the plan
has not yet created we hope to engage
all of you over the coming year uh to
participate in its in its um first in
its um in its Framing and then
eventually into its
development um I do have copies of the
full report in black and white stack
over on the table I didn't want to
overwhelm you with paper um the full
report is organized to provide a case
for the above mentioned priorities um
areas and detailed recommendations in
each of those areas and it also provides
highlights of progress made in recent
years on these
issues one final note is that the
commission produces a newsletter called
Aging matters um it's edited by a me um
a member of the commission and is
published monthly um you will be
receiving it in your legislative uh
email address it's really chocked full
of information um some of the Articles
do uh focus on policy issues um but
there are other articles that are just
um valuable information that you can
share with your constituents about State
Services community activities Etc um and
if you would like to receive it at an
alternative email address just reach out
and we'll we'll make sure you get it so
uh thank you and I'm happy to answer any
questions uh we do have there are two
people here who are actually sered on
the commission uh representative uh
Weber and representative McKay are very
grateful for their participation um it
helps to keep our work meaningful for
all of
you thank you any
questions I don't see any okay thank you
very much
okay I I also want to mentioned that uh
representative Charlie McMahon also
commission okay I have no other speakers
uh listed uh today for today uh so that
will conclude the program uh the um we
will begin our hearings next week
starting at 9:30 um we have a full day
schedule for next Wednesday and next
Thursday um as of this afternoon we
determin we have 28 bills assigned to us
so far uh and more are anticipated so
we're going to get off to a running
start next week at again 9:30 on
Wednesday look forward to seeing all of
you then thank you representative
Weber I just had one nuts and bolts
thing that I wish had asked at the
beginning of last session two years ago
but I didn't uh we have now become kind
of a traveling committee so do we still
have somewhere an office that has filing
cabinets where we can keep papers and
things and if so which one is it I I
have not been told otherwise so it
should still be 205 okay so that's our
our home base if that has been changed
then no one told me so okay thank you
very much so so for new members they
should have a drawer in a filing cabinet
that has their name on it so that they
could actually I mean it it fit a pile
of papers plus a pair of shoes so it's
very useful to the best of my knowledge
that should be the case yes
representative
pazo I have a question uh maybe to the
chair does our committee have any policy
on lobbying from agent
because for example when Karen
Hebert was speaking about testifying
here in future she told us that she will
be giving us
information but when another agency
lead Ernie Gillan was uh speaking about
what he will be presenting he made it
clear that he will be advocating for for
certain
policies uh from the agency so as far as
I understand some
committees advise
agencies uh just to give information uh
and not taking positions so I wonder
like is there any uh preference in this
committee it's I don't know of any U
restriction on an agency advocating for
a certain position uh I know often times
Health and Human Services does not take
a position on a bill they just provide
information but on other occasions they
they may offer opposition or support uh
and that's up to really the agency on a
case-by Case basis at least to the best
of my knowledge representative Weber I
don't know of anything different than
that I would say that and I also would
say that when I have subed on other
committees I have been astonished at how
very um care ful the Department of
Health and Human Services has been to be
clear about what are legislative
prerogatives and they they certainly I
mean it seems fair to me that they can
have
positions uh and communicate them to us
uh but they are also very clear that it
is the legislature who makes the final
decision on those and and I think that
Mr Williams in particular has been very
very careful uh to make that clear uh I
have been in other committees in other
years some time ago when an agency has
simply said to a legislative panel well
we're not going to agree to that and I I
find that that's where it's Troublesome
so thank
you any other questions uh we will be
meeting in and and it's my understanding
this will be our assigned room for
generally speaking for committee uh
meetings room 201 we'll be sharing that
with Public Works Public Works will be
meeting on Tuesdays we will be meeting
on Wednesdays and sometimes Thursdays as
as we will be next week so and of course
everything will be noticed in the
calendar so unless anyone has anything
else any other questions okay we stand